good morning everyone and welcome to a
special tablet week edition of Android
developers strike back
tablet a week is like Shark Week except
not nearly as boring it's true
it's very true in fact we're gonna have
a look at three tablet apps today we've
got the developers from mint tiny
company and instapaper developers as
well I think they actually call
themselves TinyCo tiny code TinyCo all
right
tiny company kind of sounds like one of
their games actually thanks to this very
Church we will ask the Tony code guys
about their naming a choice for their
brand when we speak to them so we've got
those three apps to go through we're
going to try and spend about ten minutes
on each find out a little bit about
their experience developing for tablets
but successes that have what tips
they've got for other developers are
looking to develop for tablet as well
excellent
so I think we're gonna start with mid
dog absolutely let's see if I got the
slides right maybe Oh check that out
very nice so welcome thank you for
joining so I'm going to introduce
yourself tell us a little bit about
yourself and Amit sure so my name is
Brian tan and I'm actually the product
owner for the Android side for mint.com
so I'm just happy to be here and happy
to talk a little bit about mint and kind
of our tablet experience outstanding so
I'm gonna ask the same few questions to
to everyone I think we'll start off just
tell us a little bit about mint about
the app which you've designed for tablet
you know a little bit about the
experiences around you know what makes
this a tablet specific version of you
sure so you know MIPCOM first off is a
way for you to take a look at your
finances on our tablet essentially we
aggregate all of your various accounts
you know credit accounts checking
accounts and things of that sort on the
tablet so that you can have one view of
your finances and basically stay on top
of it you know we have a website and
then we wanted to build a tablet app and
so what we did is we decided to take
kind of the best of what was on the web
and then bring it to the tablet but more
specifically you know we want to build
this thing from the ground up
make it native and then we said we want
to make it cool and want to make it
interesting finances for the most part
people don't really think of it as cool
and interesting right no it's not what I
do for fun yeah so you know on the on
the overview screen here that we've got
you know basically we've trudged just
try to make it a very rich experience
you know we have a nice little graphic
in the upper left hand corner then
keeping that up actually sure just so
that you can quickly see it kind of you
know where your finances are in terms of
what you're spending we've got nice
little bar graphs on the right and the
nice little icons that represent
spending there by the way I hope you
don't mind that I totally stole this UI
for my custom controls class I know I
didn't actually see that but that's cool
we like we like to hear that well I
remember that you guys came in to show
us this when I I think it was actually
pre honeycomb yeah and we were having
some problems because you know of course
that was a new GPU for everybody right
and there were some there were some
issues we we couldn't get it Hardware
accelerate at the normal canvas and it
wasn't working quite fast enough and you
know we looked at it wasn't buttery
smooth and you guys really wanted to be
really super smooth and so we I think we
ended up recommending that you draw it
on its own hardware yeah no definitely I
mean that was this screen right here
this many by category screen it's kind
of that one thing that we want to get
right we wanted to make sure that
interactive in your finances was kind of
this very immersive experience and that
buttery smooth you know rotation of the
screen clicking on that are tapping on
the slices even slowing down to kind of
you know move between the slices we
wanted to get that 100% right and that
was just something that we poured a lot
of effort a lot of time into it really
gives that that feeling that this is an
app that it feels solid right you know
it's like there's no jank enos there's
no oh I can see what they tried to do
there it just kind of works exactly if
you'd hope it does you can see one one
thing that may not come out in the video
but write something that really
impressed us and really made it run
slower is that there's just a really
light gradient all the way around here
and you know we talk a lot about
gradients I think you because there are
some design guides belonging to our
competitors that emphasize gradients in
a way that we find
lesk androidy but this is a great use of
gradients it's a wonderful it's you
wouldn't even know it's there if it
wasn't pointed out to you but it makes
the whole thing feel a little deeper a
little more life life and of course it
it slowed down rendering because the
gradients at that time we're done in and
software but once you rendered that all
out onto one layer then you can rotate
the layer without actually having to
redraw all the gradients every time yeah
I mean you know our designers are very
thankful that you notice the gradient
I'm thankful of it I mean again I was
just one of those things that you know
in addition to the interaction piece and
getting that right
you know the visual aspect the colors
the gradients and even kind of the blend
of the colors you know we spent a lot of
time on that and we're very very proud
of it it's one of those big challenges I
mean it seems funny like it's it's such
a deceptively simple screen that we're
looking at here it's a simple pie
well donut chart you know with a simple
sort of explanation of what each thing
represents but it's all those little
things like I've I think anyone who's
done any kind of engineering for any
amount of time has built charting
controls from scratch cuz it's like
databases it's a requirement of every
job you ever do to start from the
beginning and even simple things like
choosing what colors you're going to
have because you don't necessarily know
how many categories you're gonna have so
it's a pseudo-random color generator but
you need to make sure that each one is
noticeable and that they look well
together and you know I think that
attention to detail really works well it
ain't even making it a doughnut instead
of a pie I think and I don't know if
this is what you had in mind but it
feels like that gives me a clue that I'm
gonna interact with it instead of just
looking at it yeah well it looks like
one of those spinning wheels yeah that's
that's the one thing you know when I did
my version I had to add in with you know
spending money on faster yeah great very
cool all right so I guess the two
questions I had so the first one is so
you already had
a phone app and a website before you had
the tablet out what would you say is
sort of the the biggest change that
you've made in order to make something
which was really a great tablet
experience as opposed to the to the
phone version and and sort of you know
more than that what was the result so
you know what did you do and how has
that affected your install Raider your
engagement or any of those sorts of
things right so you know when we first
developed the tablet app as you said we
had a phone app already and you know we
weren't 100% sure kind of where folks
would fall in terms of how they would
use both apps so we said let's release a
basic version of the tablet app and then
let's kind of get some data and let's
iterate against that and so one of the
things that we started to find with a
tablet app is that people are actually
spending more time on the tablet app
basically they're sitting there they're
looking back in their finances and
they're also looking forward into their
finances they said the analysis exactly
whereas on the phone it's kind of like
this decision maker you know like you
might be at the store and you might
decide should I really buy this TV
saying you figure out yes I can choosing
my consumer electronics budget for this
right exactly and then so we started to
move down that route of empowering the
user on the tablet to do things like you
know editing budgets and doing split
transactions and just being able to do
more in terms of really kind of setting
their their financial foundation and you
know looking back at their data and
making sure it's kind of jiving with
what they think so you know our analogy
is our phone app is basically a snacking
app like throughout the day your pop and
peanuts you're you know eating you know
candy bars and whatnot and then with the
tablet app it's basically like a full
meal you sit down and you'll kind of
digest the overview and then you'll you
know go deeper into budgets and you
start editing your budgets and things of
that sort I like that that's a nice
analogy so um if I understand that
correctly so you actually are you
actually putting your spending into the
app as you're spending it so if you're
out at the shops you're actually putting
that's that budgetary information in by
the phone app yeah so basically on your
tablet app you can go and set your
budgets you can edit your budgets and
then when you have your phone app you
know that very same budget that you've
said you can clearly see how much money
you've got left to this particular month
and then you can dive deeper into the
various you know subcategories and
whatnot and
you know conversely when you're on your
phone you can enter transactions on the
go and on the fly and then when you get
home you know you can see them show up
on your tablets and linking it all in
and do a little bit more if you wanted
to so you can find out what punishment
you've done to your budgets yeah on your
phone when you get back on yeah that's
nice so so does that mean that the the
tablet app is that something that's sort
of a feature for feature equivalent of
what you can do on the website you do
sort of see that in the future is sort
of becoming more and more the way that
maybe people are going to be using the
app definitely I mean you know you kind
of hit the nail on the head in terms of
you know we've got a website we've got a
tablet we've got a phone you know where
the tablets sit in between and it's
looking more and more like you know it
may kind of replace the web it may kind
of you know we'll bring some of those
more web like features to the tablet and
then we'll keep the phone to be very
simple very decision oriented or kind of
enter information oriented and then on
the tablet you can do your analysis I
mean that's I think something which we
go on about quite a bit which is the
idea that on a on a phone you really
want to have almost a single action so
you open it up and there's sort of one
or two steps to do whatever it is you
want to do check to see whether I can
buy this thing or you know basically
enter the information that I have bought
this thing right whereas on the tablet
you are expecting people to sit down and
spend a bit more time so you can have a
little bit more of a complex workflow
and have more complex actions yeah and
our day that tells us exactly that I
mean you know to the point about
snacking and dining I mean on the tablet
app you know we see most people hopping
on into the app at about 8:00 you know
after 8:00 p.m. and that's what our
usage spikes between 8:00 and 10:00 so
you know maybe folks put the kids down
to bed and then they pick up meant full
you know they're maybe they're in bed
talking with their wife or husband or
whatnot I really need this TV and look
we can make it exactly I can say dice
that's cool and so did you see then
obviously we've got a lot of analytics
which is again something which we tell
people that they need to do you know you
need to understand what impact the
decisions you're making about your app
has on its usage so did you see as you
were sort of adding more of that dining
experience to tablet that you're in huge
was increasing yeah definitely I mean
we've seen you know
a fair amount of usage in terms of just
you know installs in the app and then
just in terms of you know overall time
spent in the app you know I believe the
number was in the magnitude of 25
percent more time on the app you know
versus on the phone so you know again
big big thing for us
you know to know that and to kind of
make that decision and go down that path
very cool that sounds like it sounds
like a lot of thought and if it has gone
into every aspect of this which is
really great to see and you can see that
from that the polished effect yeah the
other thing I want to point out as well
because we had mint I think was one of
the nominees for one of our our clinics
a while back but we didn't spend much
time on it because a it was already
great and B we didn't have a demo
account right but you know one thing I
want to highlight for people watching is
that this is an app that looks very much
like I mean it doesn't it doesn't look a
lot like holo it's got more gradients
than we would usually expect to see
things like these reflections but it
really works oh yeah you know and I
think that's something which we spend a
lot of time telling people like
sometimes you can watch our show and
think we're basically saying make every
app look like it should be a native app
like you know that is shipped with the
phone right make everything flat exactly
flat what and yeah thing to be fair
Roman Nurik does say that but this is a
really good example of going the whole
way so it's like it doesn't have to be
that this still looks consistent with
Android it looks like it belongs on this
device but it does look different to
some of the native apps which ship with
it and I think it really just comes down
to having this holistic design that fits
everything in you know you've got this
action bar which looks like a legitimate
action bar and it is you've got it works
right everything everything's in the
right place that's right if I wanted
affecting me and can refresh I know here
I've got you know the compose icon
meaning you know to add something in it
it's all intuitive it all works the way
I was expected and nothing now I have I
don't think I've seen every nook and
cranny of this app but just as I played
with it this is probably the fourth or
fifth time I've had a chance to sit down
and play with it what's really
impressive is that nothing feels
stitched on there's there's never that
point that we get to with a lot of other
apps where we say Oh
where they ran out of time and stop this
is where the design resources ran out in
a development well you know what I could
do right and and you can see that
they've solved a lot of difficult
technical problems look this is it this
is a buttery smooth thing whatever if
you notice but there's a little fade out
grating I did which I actually you know
isn't in fact I I will say that a couple
of versions ago there were some devices
where we had to take that gradient out
because we couldn't make our GPU code
run fast enough this is a really good
example actually of using the
inspiration of Hollow and of the Android
theming and apply it within your own app
because we you know we have something
similar to this when you get to the top
and bottom of a list view and this
clearly isn't a list view but it still
has that same hinting as to there is
more up here yeah it's really nice
alright very cool all right so I think
we've probably spent enough time on on
mint so thank you very much for coming
in and joining us and talking a little
bit about the product and we should give
some other guys a chance
so absolutely let's move on to TinyCo
indeed can you guys hear us
and there's chair for you oh cool hey
guys hi how are you hey hey we're just
gonna shift around here cuz ya gonna
have any high-tech waited we need like a
little chair carousel we need like a
trapdoor cuz we're on the we're on the
second floor that's scary cuz we're in
the u.s. so just lower people out and
all of them back in exactly as long as
when we get an ADK project we can
expense it absolutely hahaha
so first question TinyCo yes not tiny
company yes tiny curl excellent that's
probably a good choice so apologies for
mangling your company name desert you
introduce yourself so it tell us a
little bit about tinypic
sure I'm I'm Sean Maher I'm one of the
mobile developers here we make mobile
games most of them are freemium games
with in-app purchase and yeah we've been
moving
everything that we can onto the Android
store and trying to support as many
devices as possible including the
tablets outstanding so let's say say
we've installed Tiny Monsters I think on
the device you've got it up on screen
you want to tell us a little bit about
the game perhaps it looks great on
tablet so maybe talk a little bit about
the the tablet aspects and any
differences that this may have with the
phone version sure yeah I mean we
pictured that people would be using the
the tablet version you know maybe at
their desks but probably on their couch
or in bed or something like that we
definitely knew that people wanted to
get a bigger and better view of their
island for anyone who hasn't played the
game you you have your own island that
you decorate and by habitats in and then
you hatch and raise different monsters
and then crossbreed them but but we
wanted to make sure that people got as
big and as clear view of the island as
possible so we took advantage of the
full side of the size of the screen and
we made sure that we had high resolution
assets for for all of the buildings all
of the monsters everything that people
would be seeing yes that's looks
fantastic I think it's the first thing
that I noticed like you've got the full
screen experience with the sort of the
chrome the game chrome is big enough
without being too big so it doesn't look
like it's been stretched but it's all
big enough to touch and the assets just
look gorgeous
really gross yeah you guys have come
such a long way since I remember when we
first got in touch you guys were working
on was it tap resort or the is a little
island game yes yeah that would have
been tempers or yeah and and that was
the first thing that we noticed was you
know the the assets didn't didn't scale
very well and there's you know a lot of
things that come over from phone and I
remember we sat down and talked to you
about you know the different you know
form factors in Android and took a while
but it seems like I you guys really took
that to heart I mean didn't you go back
and basically you wrote a cross-platform
engine which works really well we're
able to get great performance out of it
but most importantly you've got these
images
just fantastic even at these really high
zoom I'm very impressed fantastic yeah
we we did we were originally with the
older game that you were talking about
we were porting our apps and essentially
had two different code bases running but
always when we started to take this very
seriously we knew that we needed a
cross-platform engine which we wrote and
probably one of the biggest challenges
was how are we gonna deal with all these
different aspect ratios and because we
knew that we were we were now dealing
with more than one screen size and just
stretching everything wasn't going to to
cut it you know one thing I do remember
too is that you know that we we had a
talking I think you actually if I
remember right had a an excellent blog
post about just how you were able to
grow your revenue by concentrating on
treating and leur Android like Android
instead of porting from some other
platform that didn't have the same
benefits and challenges right yeah it
has been a whole different it's a whole
different ecosystem and and different
strategies have worked well for us I'm a
coder so I'm not I probably can't speak
too much to the to the financial side of
things but we we have treated each
platform on the engineering side it's
all fairly unified but the monetization
strategies are very different on each
ecosystem yeah that's interesting you
know given that you are on the
engineering side
I'd like to dig a little bit deeper if
possible to find out you know what were
some of the techniques that you use to
get past the that challenge that you
said of all the different aspect ratios
and screen sizes is there something that
you can share with some of the
developers watching - you're probably
facing a lot of those same issues sure
sure absolutely
like a like a lot of games we're using
the NDK we're writing the bulk of our
game code in C++ and the like I said
right out of the gate we knew we needed
to deal with this not so much the screen
size issue but the aspect ratio issue
some devices are extremely widescreen
others are taller you know than
the standard you know four by three
phone aspect ratio a lot of games which
have sort of the black Basel on the side
to say really is for three trust me
right yeah we we don't we don't pretend
that it's for three we actually so since
we're using the the native development
kit we're not using a lot of the
built-in Android features for for
scaling and whatnot
we look at the raw number of pixels on
the screen and based on that decide how
much we're gonna have to scale the UI
elements and the game elements beyond
that we do have high resolution assets
that we use if we do decide we need to
scale a button to twice its original
size we use a double sized art asset for
that so it doesn't look blurry like it
would be if you just if you just scaled
it up without using a larger asset
that's a really interesting point do you
make that decision initially based on
the screen size which assets you'll load
or do you actually make it on an asset
by asset basis trying to determine how
much it's going to scale we don't do the
the second technique you're talking
about would be like level of detail
based on how big it is decide which
asset to use we don't do that we decide
based on the the raw number of pixels in
the display we think we're gonna need
you know single size assets or double
size assets so do you bucket them I'm
really curious your bucket on the same
way we do or do you have a different
scheme I'm not sure if you I know in the
in the standard Android SDK there's a
number of folders for medium resolution
and high resolution and things like that
we have what we call just the single
resolution the One X and the double
resolution the the two X we're not using
other intermediate sizes gotcha that
makes sense in effect we've we've
actually found that for most cases that
actually works pretty well like it's not
always necessary even when you're using
the SDK to use each of those buckets and
in fact when you're you know just
providing something very high res which
can then scale back
works pretty well until you get to the
point where you almost needed a
different style asset to work at the
reduced resolution yeah of course you're
also doing some some quite fancy scaling
work here yeah sort of zooming in on the
on the world
yeah we're zooming in and out and is
that just a set of mipmap textures or or
DUI we're actually we're we're not using
the maps we're just using this single
the single high resolution texture
that's why you can zoom in as far as you
are so that a single building fills up
the entire screen Wow because because we
are using those those high resolution
textures yeah yeah MIT maps are really
nice for scaling but of course they use
a lot more memory and we are still
somewhat memory constrained that's
really interesting
why would it be well I would actually be
very interested to to know how that
affects your performance because
typically you know we'll see is new maps
will take up more more room in memory
obviously but they'll also I render
faster exactly because they're less GPU
bandwidth on the way in right so I'm
actually really surprised that you're
able to get this framerate with nothing
but full resolution samples right well
we were we just we've always been more
constrained by memory than we were by by
CPU and draw speed that may be because
we don't have millions of triangles on
the on the screen but for us for the
kind of games that we're making right
now it made more sense to use less
memory and and take the hit to the draw
speed gotcha yeah it certainly it just
looks really smooth so I think that's
probably a good choice I love the
graphics like oh the graphics look
fantastic you know for all of the even
just just this this style itself and
sort of the faces from the people who
pop up and congratulate oh yeah
absolutely it looks like a lot of fun
well I remember I was actually in the
pitch meeting when you guys came and
showed this too so the first time and
we'd actually just reviewed a whole set
of very very similar games but this
really blew us away then you know kudos
to your artist well thank you yeah I
can't take credit for that we have some
amazing artists and some amazing UI
people very cool
so I was going to ask him and you may
not be you may not be the right person
on the team to speak to this what I'll
ask anyway just in case having you know
really build this excellent experience
on tablet do you have you found any
significant difference in terms of user
engagement and I mean frankly you guys
have an app which you know is paid so if
you found that you're making
comparatively more money on on users who
are using it on tablet devices
yeah I don't I I don't have access to
the monetization numbers but I do know
that the percentage of our users who are
playing on a tablet has been definitely
been going up over time
and it's we definitely take that into
consideration when planning new features
because we know that that's where a lot
of our users want to play on a tablet
that makes a lot of sense you know it's
particularly for games like this which
are sort of more than that just I've got
five minutes while I'm waiting for my
bus it's more like okay I've got an hour
to spend gaming now whether that's on a
train or at home or wherever else so I'm
you know for that experience I think
tablets as well and especially one when
you want that really beautiful immersive
graphical experience I mean this you
know you can see very similar graphics
on the phone but they just won't blow
you away like they do here I I know that
publicly you guys have have said a few
things about how Android was very
disappointing at first for for TinyCo
but as we as we worked with you and as
as you started to see the Android
ecosystem as a separate thing especially
you know being able to take advantage of
things like different aspect ratios
different size devices in a way that
made the users of each device happy then
you know apparently and this is again
what you guys send your blog post say
the monetization just steadily climbed
and and got much much better and I don't
know where it's at now that was I think
a last year is when you guys were saying
that actually before this game even came
out
but it's great to see that it's well
you'd like to think so at the very least
I think if we're seeing you know apps
games of this sort of quality and you
guys are still investing the resources
to create them for tablets that's
probably a good sign no holy crap you
get clouds and everything yeah I was
wondering what the things were bounce is
cool all right well we've we've spent a
bunch of time on this we should give a
little bit of a chance to instigate the
display thank you very much for joining
us and thank you trading an awesome
looking game thank you guys all right
let's move on such a nice little
animation you got going there in pressed
it's it's almost like magic the way it
moves like yeah it's moving magically so
the the last step that we wanted to talk
about today was Instapaper
so hopefully we've got the Instapaper
guys on the line hi guys
pretty good thank you for for bearing
with us and hanging around we're
hopefully saving the best to last no
offense to everyone has just gone before
it's supposed to get them out of the
room right oscar-winner so please
introduce yourself tell us a little bit
about the company the app sure
so our company's fault mobilux my name
is Jeff Rock I'm co-founder I'm here
with Jason Hamrick who's our lead
Android developer so mobilux we make
apps for iOS the Mac Android pretty much
anywhere there's a screen a lot of our
business is building white label apps
for other other companies and startups
so tumblr we built their first and
second-generation android client you
know i homes android client for their
alarm clock
we built other apps for Random House and
it's some other guys out there on the
store you just you may not see our name
but you have a lot of people using our
apps may not have seen the and may not
have seen the name be probably used one
of your apps
yeah we this arrangement was a little
different
good friends with Marco Arment and he
came to us and said look I just simply
don't have the resources to devote to
Android development and I know you guys
do this stuff and he was interested in
seeing if we would build it under our
name cuz he felt like into people would
really shine on android tablets so we we
took it over and we developed the
Android code base from scratch we
maintain it we work closely with Marco
on the features were going to implement
timeline but it is very much a mobilux
slash in the midst of paper production
very cool very cool so he came to you
guys specifically because you've got
that experience with Android and and
sort of understand how to build an app
which is sort of a pure Android
experience azarith yeah I think we're
all especially Mobile X in particular
and Marco I know he feels this way -
really we love the the kind of write
once run anywhere in frameworks we don't
in our experience we've never seen any
of those do it particularly well and
I've never heard of anyone that loved
them yeah that's what everyone I think
pretty finicky about being native for
the platform I've done the way it
suposed yeah I think that's what it
comes down to me and those write once
run anywhere type platforms are a great
idea and I'd be hugely supportive of
them if they produced awesome apps which
I couldn't tell we're built on our right
once you know run anywhere type platform
so that doesn't seem to be the case
every time I've ever you know
encountered any sort of automatically
generated UI it's it's never good yeah
exactly so you know I think at the
moment it's definitely the way to go is
to really try and build something that
is you know native for each one it I
mean that's the thing as well people act
as though it's a huge amount of
Extraordinary losing you just a little
bit you say that's all right we're just
basically talking amongst ourselves but
I say you guys a person in a screen as
well so we'll continue to talk amongst
ourselves until you unfreeze it looks
like that back no good I can see
something yeah I've seen them in that
corner oh great great yeah so we were
sight I think people forget actually the
lessons of history because if you think
about even
you know the the first version of
Microsoft Office for Mac for instance
and Office for Mac a lot of people don't
realize is actually very profitable and
well-respected product but the first
version was universally reviled it was
mostly because they took their Windows
product and plopped it directly on the
Mac yeah that's never gonna fly right
and an it doesn't fly to go back the
other way either I've had some some
things that were obviously written for
Mac on my Windows machine and they just
don't jibe right it's all the little
things it's like you hit a drop-down and
the drop-down in Mac and Windows is
different it's exactly the same
functionality but it looks different and
it's that cognitive dissonance where
you're like wait how do I select this oh
okay
that slight little pause breaks you out
of that mindset of whatever it is that
you were doing is you don't want to have
to think about the app you just want to
be able to do whatever the app lets you
do right so respecting the platform and
and respect the user who chose to buy
that slat form it's like you don't have
to worry about us you know we can take
it but it's about the users which are
trying to you know leverage your app so
we've got we've got Instapaper up on the
screen can you tell us a little bit
about the the way that you went about
designing a tablet specific version of
the app and sort of what are the the key
decisions that you made and how that has
affected usage of the app yeah
absolutely
so I think unlike a lot of Android
development
we started with tablet primarily we
actually designed out the 7-inch and
10-inch layouts or tablet before we even
looked at the phone based layouts that's
really felt like this was for for for
people that read no there's a lot of
competition in this space now for read
it later style you know consumption but
instead papers really for reading and as
soon as we picked up a 7-inch tablet we
really knew that that was that was a
great place to be we we deploy onto
Kindle as well with the same same way
outs and nook that was very important
because we wanted to get the people that
were we're buying primarily reading
devices as well as certain people
in the Google Playstore that have these
tablets so it was a pretty easy decision
to make once once we held those tablets
that the phone would be a secondary
place to run as the paper and most
likely you're gonna want sit down on the
couch or land that and read on a nice
just just looking at it here I can see
straight away what it reminds me of is
my Kindle you know just a great
experience for being optimized for being
able to read content so it's it's a very
simple display very sparse without being
too small which i think is important
yeah we are we really were we're focused
on simplicity Instapaper is not a
complex interface we have a lot of
opportunities to create little UI
mechanisms that are fun or or maybe a
little overly complex and means this you
know when we be for instant paper this
it really the simplicity of the
experiences is core I think to that
whole product oh I totally agree I think
you know it's like you start up the app
and it almost looks and I say this with
respect
it almost looks a little boring you know
you open it up and it's like oh it's
just a bunch of things to read and then
you click them and there's articles to
read but that I think it's kind of the
point right there there's no distraction
there's no oh what does this app do how
do I use this what features that are
available is like yeah there aren't any
crazy pop-ups or gigantic menus it's
just a bunch of really that you've
chosen to read and provide it in a way
for you optimized for you to be able to
read it you know I love the fact that
you can change the the fonts and the
profile and everything else you know the
other thing that I noticed about this
design that I think is really
interesting as a lot of people well
almost everyone I think that writes a
tablet app will start with a two column
layout there's a you know a
master-detail type of yeah like sort of
navigation on your left with you know
detail on the right right sorry I and
you guys did not do that you you go with
a two column view that's it makes me
think of a newspaper and I think that's
very effective is it's really
interesting layout and so that just
goes to the same tenant and we believe
that the content is king and in some
favor and we want to give you as much
content without without you know we're
not just space-filling here we put two
columns up so that you could see the
most recent articles that you saved or
get a little bit more content on the
screen so you can quickly and get into
that reading experience yeah I think
it's a really good point but a lot of
the way that this is presented is like
you say sort of inspired by newspapers I
would say you know in that you can fit
probably as many articles probably not
quite as many if you just had this
listed vertically with the same amount
of text but it would look kind of weird
because you'd have these really long
lines I wouldn't be nearly as readable
either no absolutely not
and so here you've kind of taken that
approach which we've learned from
however many decades of printing
newspapers that people can read columns
much more easily than lots of long flat
strings and so I love to see apps which
take things which we've learned from
other industries and saying well you
know what it's actually not that
different what you creating here is an
instant paper or a way for people to be
able to come to to quickly scan browsing
and read content yeah and in fact I have
to say now when I when I click through
to one of the stories and it takes up
the entire width of the screen I'm
actually kind of disappointed that's
that's interesting I mean I think it's
one of the bigger challenges so I'd be
interested to know when you're sort of
looking at the the detailed view for any
of the articles you know how much of
this is reformatted how much of it are
you displaying this just I say just are
you displaying this in a web view and
just pulling the raw content out are you
doing any kind of reformatting to it
yeah so the Asteria provides the
basically overall HTML content we pull
that down and cache it locally on your
SD card or your local storage and then
we have a web view that that just opens
up that content and we apply a cascading
style sheet to that and some JavaScript
as well and that allows you to different
things like changing the font size to
change the font change the line spacing
line height the margins that kind of
stuff very cool
it would be em yeah yeah they've got
this whole exactly this we're just sort
of clicking on the on the font control
dialog here and one of the things that I
guess I want to point out is that again
this is another example of an app which
doesn't strictly conform to like
standard expectations of how an app
should look but it does do some of the
it's pretty much the same so you've got
the the standard share icon on what
looks like an action bar which has
actions it's obvious the way that it's
working I'd kind of like to see an up
affordance here but that's kind of
getting a little bit nitpicky I think
that as as the up affordance becomes
more and more common people are going to
start really missing it hmm so that's
some of this work you gotta remember
that to target things like the Nook the
last write took a point oh we had to go
back two to one and that that presented
some some interesting problems that
action bar is not actually you know the
Ice Cream Sandwich action bar that was
built so as the code base kind of
modernizes and edie we can you know the
new Kindles and the new nooks that
they've moved off the older codebase
thereof Ice Cream Sandwich now so we're
gonna be able to kind of move up to
using more system frameworks which would
rather be using anyway quite honestly
one of those things were I don't want to
say they're hats
creative guys would like to see right
yeah now that's fair enough so I mean I
guess what you guys are saying is if
we'd given you a backwards compatible
action bar you would have used it but we
didn't say you had to do what you could
that's a that's a familiar story yeah
honestly I there's really only one thing
after playing at the app for a while
that that bothered me and that's this
dis which for dark mode yeah that that
looks like it may have been lifted from
somewhere else yeah the the dock mode
switch the thing which bothers me more
so than the look is that it's it's not
hugely responsive yeah I found myself
wanting to swipe it right but you have
some happens wipe it's a tap yeah
and having yeah something that looks
like a ball the that's
we palpable is actually really
frustrating well I'm sorry we lost you
for a minute there what element are you
talking about slick see what you did
that the the dock mode yeah it looks
like a yeah it's gonna change we know
and again some of those were yeah time
limitations and we really wanted to get
something out the market but we're
definitely constantly looking at this
interface and we're gonna be adapting it
very cool I mean I think that's the the
key to this is is it simplicity so for
any of the nitpicks that we have around
navigation it's it's actually not too
big a deal because it's it's really
straightforward you've only got two
levels of now you can never really get
lost because there's only so far you can
go and you're never sort of trying to
figure out where it where are you out
how does this all work it really is that
that epitome of something which is easy
to use and again one of the things that
we talk about a lot when we talk about
designing for tablet is to make sure
that you don't have excessive whitespace
and I think one of the tricks that a lot
of people do is they just fill it up
with fragments or whatever to just have
not as long lines and so I think that's
you know I know we've talked about this
a lot but I think that's what you've
done really well here is thought beyond
that as to well how can we feel this in
a way that makes it a better experience
rather than just a less sucky experience
and not just better but more appropriate
to the activity at hand you know we were
at the very beginning of the show we we
looked at mint calm which also filled
space really really well and they did it
by having sort of a multi pane view that
felt like a you know a little bit like a
spaceship control center which i think
was really appropriate to this idea of
controlling your money whereas this
feels a lot more like it just opened up
the the afternoon paper i'm going to
take a really I think that's a really
good observation is sort of that
difference where mint did have sort of
the gradients and the and the rounding
to make it sort of a more rich sort of
3d sort of experience and this is
exactly the opposite this is about as
flat as a napkin
without disappearing into the background
entirely it's it's quite monochromatic
it doesn't have blends or gradients or
anything like that because well books or
newspapers don't write it's just black
and white text optimized for you to be
able to read but of course you know you
can see where where they've wanted to
they have you know put in some nice
design touches it's not that it's not
designed it's not it's designed this way
I think that's a really important thing
you know it's it's tempting for us as
engineers I think sometimes to go oh
look at the things I can do yeah and
then to do them but that can sometimes
detract from a much more simple
experience which can be a easier well
we'll be really looking forward to your
next release I know there's a bunch of
little things I think we've given some
feedback already you know there was that
button the the the weight icons are laid
out on the action bar doesn't quite fit
the brand new guidelines it just came
out a few months ago but I think you
guys are aware of all that and can't
wait to see what you guys come up with
in your next version definitely the
other thing I did want to ask you guys I
think we're well over the time we had
initially trying because we
optimistically budgeted half an hour for
talking to three different developers
that were very interested in talking to
exactly it's we don't care if anyone
else is watching we've had a really good
time is quite room that so the one thing
I did want to ask so you started with
tablet have you built a phone version as
well now no absolutely yeah and I think
it more files into your guidelines than
the newer guidelines actually medical
than the tablet interface does but yeah
we absolutely run on on phones at every
density and screen layout size including
the newer but the Galaxy Note layout
which is a weird place but yeah we've
got layouts for for all phones very cool
so I guess the one question I had then
is based on that have you seen a
difference in a user engagement on
tablet versus phone are people reading
longer on the tablet versions of those
metrics that you guys collect yeah we do
know that while people will use the
phone or the tablet really at three many
times a day right while they're eating
breakfast father eating lunch and once
the
and they're around dinnertime but we we
have noticed that later in the day is
more tablet heavy hmm so we're seeing a
lot more tablet ease and I think kind of
like when people are sitting down III
guess all these commercials in the there
all right I mean we're in debt or
sitting on the couch watching a geek
pull out their tablet for me it's right
when my 4G LTE phone runs out of battery
that's why I'm kind of tablet very nice
alright perfect so we've like I said we
are well out of time but thank you guys
very much for coming on and telling us
about Instapaper and your experiences
there and thank you to all of our guests
for from mint TinyCo for joining us as
well and thank you everyone for watching
and we will be back tomorrow for the app
clinic yes indeed it's going to be a
very special episode of the app clinic
by which I mean it will be an episode
that will run excellent that is special
that's very specially we are looking at
a video player app switcher we were
going to look at last week but decided
that we needed to have a full extra week
to really understand what was going on
in those apps yes so do tune in tomorrow
for that we are also taking nominations
for next week's category which is
shopping apps we're actually going to
choose the apps that we're going to look
at during tomorrow's show before
tomorrow's show so I do make sure if
you've got a shopping app you'd like us
to take a look at that you do throw it
into the moderator queue thanks again
for watching my name is rater I'm Ian
and we'll catch you later